hey guys i'm ryan right so today I'm
gonna be talking about fear the walking
dead series premiere episode I wanted to
say I want a lot of you guys to check
this alley if you haven't seen it you
don't need to watch the walking dead at
all you know need to see a single
episode in order to understand this show
so be cool to get the insights of people
who have seen the walking dead and are
watching this and who haven't seen the
walking dead but are really hooked into
this show like I watched it with
Veronica and Veronica is not into the
walking dead whatsoever she hates
anything zombie-related but I forced her
to watch the series premiere with me and
she [ __ ] loved it and she wants to
watch the whole season so it'd be really
cool to see what you guys have to say so
if you don't have aim see if you don't
have time warner cable i went on
amazon.com and I rented it for like
three dollars so it's like the perfect
place to go to ok so this is going to be
a non-spoiler review I'm going to be
doing a spoiler review of this but for
those who haven't seen the episode yet
like I said I'm or a lot people to watch
this and I figured I'd get my initial
like feelings reaction to it personally
I [ __ ] loved it I thought it was
brilliant and I really feel that there's
a lot of critics who don't know what's
in store for this series like if you
look at the clever writing of the
walking dead what those writers do how
they tell a specific story for the whole
season and how each episode
progressively gets more intense
throughout the season till the final
episode that season and where it's just
like oh my god I gotta catch the next
one now I can already feel this show is
doing that and it had a great first
episode and a wonderful opening a
brilliant ending the journey the middle
of it was good the show managed to do
something that I wasn't too sure they
could really pull off it felt incredibly
fresh it doesn't feel like the walking
dead in a lot of ways it just feels like
a brand new zombie series like you don't
have to call this fear The Walking Dead
I mean yeah it's in the same universe
the same zombie rules apply there's so
many variations of zombie movies I'm
sure we'll get a variation of zombie
television shows now we're already
starting to get it totally different and
I love the way it is so the walking dead
the original series
episode the setup of is that the
apocalypse has already happened zombies
have already taken over the world this
one is taking place like right when the
virus is starting to slowly spread so a
lot of people might think like oh what's
the point of this show if we already
know the zombies are gonna win they're
gonna have the apocalypse and all that
I'm not here to state the point of this
show I'm not gonna speak for the writers
but there is a lot of reasons why I
think you should watch this show first
off I will say if you like The Walking
Dead more than likely you're gonna like
this series if you haven't seen the
walking dead you know how much people
love that [ __ ] show so why don't you
just hop on the bandwagon for fear the
walking dead so you could be part of the
cool crowd trust me I know what it's
like to not be part of the cool crowd I
really wish I was into Game of Thrones
more there you go just lost a lot of
respect and a lot of people just exited
the video now because I said that this
series has a different tone there's a
different vibe I'm really surprised by
the amount of people i'm hearing say
that the show is slow by notice that
complaint is usually followed by there's
not much zombie action in it if that's
all you want this show will not be that
rewarding for even in the walking dead
that a lot of episodes not really about
the walkers and I think this show like
moves significantly faster than the
walking dead watch an episode of the
walking dead and then watch the series
premiere of this you'll be like yeah
that one's way faster paced because of
the world that the walking dead takes
place in it's like a slow-moving
survival tension thriller this world is
our world its modern-day where it's a
lot more energy we got a lot of things
that people in The Walking Dead don't
have like cell phones and internet
television all kinds of media stuff and
what this show does well is it knows how
to use the media stuff really well we're
really adds to the story in this world
and shows that this is different another
thing they showed as well it gives us
really strong characters the walking
dead characters are [ __ ] awesome you
know good amount of them at least and
this show does it and they have totally
different types of characters because in
the walking dead they're just immediate
like survivors you know so there's like
a trauma
in all these dudes and this one it's
like they're all traumatized it's a
dysfunctional family we're focusing on
but it's like real-life human drama
problems not oh my god everyone i know
is dead problems it was interesting as i
found myself really invested in the
drama of these characters what it does
great is guess it's it's not that focus
on the zombies throughout it's more so
the drama of these characters and I'd
like how they really make us get
invested in these characters and it's
your scene it's a built-up show one
thing these zombie movies need is like
we need to be invested in these
characters but people want zombie action
some does Ombey movies and I all we
can't have them be more than two hours
at least this is a television show so
yeah I'm totally on board for them for
their first episode to be primarily
character that way when the zombie [ __ ]
starts occurring it's gonna be on the
edge of your seat that cell phone ring
went off at the right time another thing
I think people are failing to recognize
is that there's a lot of drama occurring
that isn't oh my god what I don't think
a lot of people realize is that yes
there's a lot of drama occurring outside
of zombie [ __ ] but at the same time all
the dramas occurring because of the
zombie incident of the beginning of this
show so even though we're not seeing the
zombies a lot of time it's still all
revolving around what is to be the
apocalypse and that event that occurs it
causes the main characters this
dysfunctional family to have to try and
work past emotional barriers and I found
myself really engrossed in that [ __ ] I
wasn't like when the [ __ ] are more
zombies gonna appear like what why are
people so just like do you really just
want a show to start off with a [ __ ] ton
of zombies and then progressively just
have [ __ ] ton more zombies you [ __ ]
phone I ain't filming anyway it does
something great where you're invested in
these characters before there are even
aware and apocalypse is on its way yeah
when they give you scenes and teases
that the zombie apocalypse is going to
be on its way those scenes are
terrifying because you feel the fear for
those characters and the fact that you
know the apocalypse is going to happen
kind of aids to the fear because you're
like oh man these people are really like
don't real
is that they're [ __ ] this really is
about the journey it's really about
these characters and they hinted details
that we might get to explore like how
the government the military starts
responding to this situation what they
decide to keep from the public what they
decide to reveal to the public like
could the government's plan this be a
major factor as to why the zombies took
over and I know people are gonna argue
like well The Walking Dead says this and
first season said this so the zombie
apocalypse was gonna occur regardless
nature will take over but maybe this
show is going to offer us something
different where like maybe that's the
real ex maybe we can get a cure now
another thing this show does really well
in the first episode it takes its time
to explore the survival instincts of man
like that human nature of survival
before the zombie [ __ ] starts really
going down you know we explore that in
the walking dead but that those are
already zombies so it's like yeah of
course your survival instincts are gonna
kick in but you see other situations in
this show where you're like wow that's
what this character was talking about
now they're really showing it with this
character it's good writing it's good
writing especially with one main
character I think his name's Nick of
course I can't remember right now he's a
junkie that's not a spoiler he was
revealed like really really on in the
episode but he does a fantastic job and
at first I was like I don't really know
about this guy but as each scene went
along with him he got better and better
and by his final moment he is fantastic
and because of him I really feel like
we're gonna get more psychological
exploration of these characters and last
thing I gotta say I keep stressing that
it's really about the journey however
knowing that the apocalypse is coming it
does something really well that a lot of
prequels don't seem to know how to get
down or like knowing what result is
coming like I found myself going I know
what's coming I know the zombies will
rule the world but I'm kind of open it
doesn't happen like I've seen five
seasons of The Walking Dead and i'm
watching this first episode and i'm like
manna i'm really hoping that apocalypse
doesn't come around oh yeah like I keep
saying the show has a totally different
tone totally different vibe if you can
accept it as a totally separate show
that just happens to have the walking
dead and it's
title I guarantee you you will see why
it's great the build-up is suspenseful
and what really makes it great is all in
the details of every [ __ ] scene they
do what seems they chose to capture
really well done and those details
obviously that's what the spoiler review
is gonna be for I'm on board I don't
know if I'm gonna do an episode to
episode review but I'll definitely be
doing a series finale review so keep a
lookout for that at least anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to me talking on my
couch if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and periscope because if we
get more followers we can get even more
product placement he cigarette fluid
e-cigarettes are great they help you
with weaning off cigarettes despite all
the rumors of what other [ __ ] is wrong
with ecigarette fluid e-cigarette fluid
does get you off those bad smelling
cigarettes that cause cancer another
thing you do an e-cigarette fluid you
can isn't it mix it with your [ __ ] you
know shake it up a little bit and then
afterwards you fill your e-cigarette
with that semen / fluid of e-cigarette
stuff and then you have Jerry take a hit
of it you still doesn't know we drank my
[ __ ] what a loser what a loser e
cigarette fluid